[Music]
hey guys it's me Debbie
today we're chatting about the toxic
waste stuff you're putting in your
coffee we're facing an epidemic people
and sugars the cons of all of this
cancer diabetes heart disease
did I mention weight gain well to treat
my figure and my health I'm sticking a
Splenda it's no calories folks so it's
pretty much a no-brainer
always a pleasure Deb now before you get
too excited on the sugar front I
definitely recommend checking out the
link to my blog in the video description
below to highlight the differences
between sugars and artificial sweeteners
enough reading all the facts artificial
sweeteners are great for people want to
lose weight and they're even good for
people with diabetes so I plan on
writing this calorie free trade for
likely you're not wrong about some of
these benefits in north america we've
got a bit of an issue with sugar
sweetened beverages because they're
loaded with added sugar so artificial
sweeteners seems like a really ingenious
way help us reduce our sugar intake and
cut sugar cravings because they mimic
the flavor of sugar without the calories
ha ha finally you agreed artificial
sweeteners can help you shed those
elby's huh and you always said there's
no magic pill oh whoa whoa whoa there
Debbie like anything in nutrition
research things change and in the world
of artificial sweeteners there's new
evidence that contradicts what we once
thought we knew oh not again
girl why are you always routing things I
love on top of that a few smaller cohort
studies and observational studies as
well as some systematic reviews then the
link between artificial sweeteners and a
higher BMI but this may be more
correlation than it is causation it's
possible that the kind of people who
tend to be at higher risk of gaining
weight tend to engage in more risky
dieting behavior which we know tends to
backfire well no no that's happened to
me artificial sweeteners helped reduce
my cravings crush my appetite and help
me eat less that may be true for some
people but definitely not others well
the research in this area is mixed
with some research finding absolutely no
impact on hunger other research has
found a link between artificial
sweeteners and increase in appetite this
may be because the presence of sweetness
in the absence of calories tricks our
body into expecting some kind of
sustenance that it's not getting this is
one evidence-based theory but there's
also being research that refutes it as
well there's also another theory based
on the research that has found that
people eat more immediately following
the consumption of artificial sweeteners
probably because they're compensating
for what they think is a healthy meal I
call this the diet coke effect you think
you're being healthy by ordering the
diet coke
so that you order this super-sized fry
to go with them having said that there's
also some more research out there that
completely refutes and contradicts that
finding as well sounds confusing and
like the research is all over the place
well one thing I know for sure is that
sugar is addictive high ain't no sugar
junkie it's funny you say that Debbie
because there is some new early research
to suggest that artificial sweeteners
may carry some addictive properties
however so far this is only being tested
in animal models so it's way too early
to make any kind of conclusions from it
but definitely I want to keep my eyes on
this well what about the diabetes don't
doctors and dietitians like you
recommend them to people to help manage
their blood sugar thinking this is
actually a really interesting area
because new research suggests that
increasing your intake of artificially
sweetened beverages by one serving a day
is associated with an 8% greater
incidence of type 2 diabetes a lot of
experts believe that this is linked to
how your individual gut microbiome
changes in response to artificial
sweeteners what can't you guys figure
anything out one minute you're saying
one thing and the next is the complete
opposite make up your mind
silence community
not to confuse you any further but
another group you concluded that it's
still not clear whether there's a strong
association between type 2 diabetes and
artificial sweeteners yeah too late
you've confused me
well my peppy dippy dog walker raves
about stevia
you know the all-natural stuff we mean
well it's settled I'm hitting up Costco
and loading up on the stevia hashtag
stevia is my man you jump ship quickly
eh well stevia is the new hottest
addition to the sweeteners list and
actually was originally used for
medicinal purposes but it's natural so
it's not the same thing as artificial
sweeteners right well actually in that
2017 study that I mentioned earlier
stevia was included in that list of
artificial sweeteners that were linked
to weight gain so it seems like stevia's
the natural properties don't necessarily
protect it from some of its potential
risks on the other hand a double-blind
control study found that stevia may
actually help to reduce blood pressure
whoever at the most recent review that I
could find on the topic found that there
was not enough strong evidence to
suggest that stevia has any kind of
benefits and ultimately more research is
needed
great avi you've left me more in the
dark than ever before now what am I
gonna put into my daily triple venti
extra hot skinny nonfat no-whip no foam
latte hmm Deb this is all just food for
thought the fact of the matter is we
don't have any super strong evidence to
make any definitive conclusions as of
right now all of the sweeteners on the
market whether artificial or natural are
considered safe so I wouldn't freak out
about using anything in small amount but
we don't have any strong long-term
evidence to suggest that any of these
sweeteners
are completely benign not even the
natural stuff so until then my
recommendation is to focus less on which
sweetener to use and more on how much
sweetener to use and just start to use
less good bye sweet life
I'll miss you oh don't be so dramatic
just start with some small reductions
and your taste buds will quickly adjust
well guys I hope you enjoyed this video
if you did be sure to give it the thumbs
up leave me a comment below with what
sweeteners you use subscribe to the
channel
and I'll see you next time on Abby's
kitchen bye
[Music]